the Falcon 9 will hold just over 1
million pounds of propellant that the
vehicle will mostly burn through in less
than three minutes after liftoff and we
began loading those propellants on both
stages of the vehicle at just about T
minus 35 minutes
engine chill has started good call out
there for the engine Chill on m1d's
beginning
now starting from the top of our rocket
we have our payload fairing which safely
enclosed the 17 foot diameter fairing
which is the structure at the very top
of the rocket now this structure
protects the satellites from aerodynamic
heating loads and contamination during
ascent and once we reach the vacuum of
space we will actually jettison these
fairing halves while the second stage
continues to its final destination in
low earth orbit
and just below that payload fairing we
have the second stage that's the stage
that will take the 41 web satellites to
a low earth orbit today
that second stage will ignite its single
Merlin vacuum or mvac engine at about
two and a half minutes into flight and
then it will rely for a second time one
rp1 load is complete good call out there
we just finished loading rp1 on the
first stage
below that second stage we have the
interstage which is actually part of the
first stage
and as you can see on your screen the
carbon fiber interstage is a distinct
black color because it is unpainted TPS
or thermal protection system
now this protects the composite material
that the inner stage is made out of
at the very bottom of the first stage
there are nine Merlin 1D engines that
will get Falcon 9 off the ground and up
into the thinner parts of the Earth's
atmosphere
and shortly after liftoff the first and
second stages will physically separate
from one another and then the second
stage will continue to orbit while the
first stage will start making its way
back down to earth
the first stage is designed to be
reflown multiple times with minimal
refurbishment between flights
and today's first stage we'll actually
be flying for the 13th time and will be
attempting to land at Landing Zone 1
which is not too far from the launch pad
on your screen right now is a live view
of that Landing Zone
and if we are successful in recovering
the booster today it will Mark the
177th successful recovery of an orbital
class rocket
and lastly that large tanks are
pressurizing for strong back retract
that large trust structure you see there
is the transporter erector or te
we use it to roll the rocket out to the
pad and raise it to its vertical launch
position now the te also routes the
vehicle's fluids power and Telemetry
umbilicals from the ground systems to
the rocket and the satellites and this
is until Falcon 9 goes on internal power
and clears the pad
I liftoff Jack retract has started good
call out there we are beginning to
retract that strong back
and we do move it away to clear the way
for Falcon 9's ascent
and while we're waiting for Te
retraction we'll see the clamp arms just
below the fairing halves you can see
them starting to open right now
and following the clamp arms opening the
te will begin to pull away from the
rocket slightly and then at t0 the
ground hydraulic systems will pull the
te even further away from Falcon 9 as it
lifts off
you can see this clamp arms opening
there just below the fairing
now the first stage is connected to a
launch Mount at the base of the
transporter erector but the structure is
hinged so it will retract away from the
vehicle in preparation for a launch
you heard that call out earlier for
these strong back retraction sequence
beginning but here in just a few seconds
you should see that strong back begin to
actually recline away from falcon 9.
we are waiting for Te retraction and
it's a beautiful day in Cape Canaveral
Florida
[Music]
stage one locks load is complete
now at this point in the countdown you
just heard stage one Pogo
you heard it to call out that stage one
lot's load is complete and stage two
locks loading should finish up just
about a minute later at T minus two
minutes
at which point both see first and state
second stages will be fully loaded with
about a million pounds of kerosene and
liquid oxygen
now those white clouds that you see
forming around the Falcon are expected
we do begin to vent the chilled gas
above the Lox tank liquid surface to
maintain the pressures that we need
and you can see around the first and
second stages that as we load that super
chilled liquid oxygen it is causing
condensation in clouds to form in the
humidity of the air
second stage box looting should be
completing here shortly
and that T minus 60 seconds page two
locks load is complete there is that
call out for stage two locks loading
complete and at T minus 60 seconds
Falcon 9 will be in startup so this
means the Rockets autonomous internal
flight computers will take over the
launch countdown and just inside of T
minus two seconds we light the Merlin 1D
engine
the one web launch 17 payload continues
to be healthy and the Falcon 9 team is
tracking no issues on the rocket weather
is looking green and the range is ready
to support today's launch we do have a
backup opportunity tomorrow March 10th
at 208 PM but we are proceeding into the
final minute of terminal count
Falcon 9 is in startup
night is in startup
LD go for launch
we have that final go for launch all
systems are go for launch on Falcon 9
with the one web launch 17 Mission
payload
T-minus 30 seconds
ten nine eight seven six five four three
two one two full power and this um
cameras
page one propulsion is nominal
[Applause]
power and telemetry
Falcon 9 has successfully lifted off
from pad 40 at Cape Canaveral
launch 17 payload
now we're still going up but we're also
heading horizontally away from the
launch pad and coming up in just a few
seconds here we will be approaching the
point of a vacuum
there we go call out for that there
at the point of Max Q we throttled in
Merlin 1D engines down briefly to reduce
the loads on the vehicle
we've now throttled the engines back up
to full power then this will help us
continue to accelerate towards low
Earth's orbit
the rocket typically needs to go about
17 500 miles per hour engine chill has
started good call out there for mvac
engine chill
we need to go about 17 500 miles per
hour horizontally in order to avoid
being pulled back down to earth and
actually get into orbit so keep an eye
on that stage one Telemetry at the
bottom of your screen
now coming up we're going to have five
events in very quick succession those
are main engine cutoff or Mikko stage
separation stage one flip second engine
start one boost back burn and then from
there the fairing halves will separate
so keep an eye out for those events
again starting with main engine cutoff
coming up on that point in just about 15
seconds here so let's listen in for that
main engine cut off
stage separation confirmed
and back ignition
stage one boost back startup
and there you go you just heard and saw
main engine cut off stage separation
stage one flip and second engine start
one now we are in the middle of the
Boost back burn which you can see on the
left side of your screen there that
first stage has flipped around and is
burning three of its Merlin 1D engines
to head back towards the launch site
while the mbac on the right is pushing
the second stage into lowers orbit uh
today's mission is what we call a rtls
or return to launch site and that's
actually where we return the first stage
back to a landing pad that is actually
very close to where we took off from
now this burden should last about 50
seconds so we have about 10 seconds left
in the Boost back burn
both stages continue to look nominal
stage one boost back shutdown there we
go just had confirmation of successful
boost back burn shutdown
coming up next in just a few seconds we
will separate those fairing halves and
should get a good view of our payload
bearing separation confirmed
there we go just had successful
confirmation of boost back burn and and
the successful separation of both the
fairing halves from the second stage
now both of these halves on today's
Mission are flying for the sixth time
and we will be attempting to retrieve
them again today once they fall back to
Earth using our recovery vessel Bob
we're just about at t plus a little over
a minute in today's Mission and we are
in the first of two plan M back Burns
before satellite deployment
now at two plus six minutes and 10
seconds so a couple minutes from now you
should see on your screen the first
stages and also following nominal
trajectories
that both vehicles are on nominal
great views from the first and second
stages there
now for the entry burn of the first
stage we do re-light three of the m1d
engines on the first stage starting with
the center E9 engine followed shortly by
the E1 and E5 engines which are all in a
row and this slows the vehicle down as
it passes into the Earth ends
now we do the entry burn in order to
slow down to reduce re-entry forces
which helps us to recover and reuse our
first stage
during that entry burn Falcon 9 is
decelerating firing this three Merlin
entry Merlin engines but we're still
moving really rapidly so the vehicle
will actually fly through its own plume
and deposit some of that carbon-based
fuel such that Falcon 9 uses onto the
booster
and great views of those grid fins on
the first stage
and the Falcon 9 first stage that is
supporting today's Mission will perform
this entry burn
for the 13th time having previously
supported multiple missions including
GPS
Vehicles four and five inspiration four
action one now outside 301 and seven
separate Sterling patients
entry Burns starting here shortly
there's one entry burn startup
here is the start of the entry burn
stage one entry burn shutdown
good entry burn from the first stage
stage one FTS has saved
flight termination system is safe for
stage one
you can see there's attitude control
testers on the first stage firing there
both vehicles continue to follow nominal
trajectories
those first and second stages are
looking good
and our next Milestone is the stage one
Landing bird which is coming all the way
back to Landing Zone one in Cape
Canaveral
starting in about 15 seconds here
stage one transonic
stage 2 FTS has saved
the H1 Landing burn
start of our stage one Landing burn
great Drone footage of the first stage
that you can see on the right hand side
of your screen
incredible views from first stage coming
down
that was a beautiful Landing
beautiful Landing of the first stage and
there you have it that Landing March the
terminal guidance
that Landing March space X's 177's
recovery of an orbital class rocket
including the first stage Landings of
Falcon 9 and heavy
and now back to stage two stage two is
looking good with just about 10 seconds
left before second engine cut off one
and back shut down
that's that call out for mvac shutdown
we're just waiting on confirmation of a
good orbit
nominal orbit insertion
you just heard that good call out for
nominal orbital insertion the ignition
isn't over yet the second stage is now
embarking on its First Coast phase now
after this Coast phase we will re-light
that mvac engine for a second time
around the t plus 55 minute mark